chris hemsworth as you guys have hung
out and Australia together whatever I
would think would be intense did you
like it Australia I love it there I
absolutely love it and and he lives down
in Byron Bay which is his beautiful town
in a beautiful part of the world and so
we've gone down there for these extended
periods and I call them adventures that
we you know with the kids and we go down
and we camp and we do all kinds of fun
stuff and but there are like everything
in Australia wants to kill you yes I I
taped something there I don't know maybe
five six months ago and went out on like
a walk in the woods with a camera a
camera you know crew and a guy and
everything he pointed to that's you know
that bark right there on that tree he's
made of acid and will kill you
that flower bites people and kills them
right literally everything that comes
out of the ground wants you to die yeah
it's kind of incredible and then even
the things that don't want you to die
like there's a spider down there called
the Huntsman mm-hmm and and it's not not
the movie that's the movie yeah but uh
but these things are massively huge and
they're actually they're not poisonous
but I mean if they if they bite you it
really really hurts but but they're
they're the spider you want to have
around because they kill the released
poisonous spiders no but they're around
like around like we had this Airbnb we
were staying in and I was talking to my
wife in the morning we're having coffee
and she was sitting on the couch and I
was sitting across in this chair and as
I was talking to her I saw this thing
that's bigger than my hand kind of come
up the wall behind her I mean it was
this massive hairy spider and I really
calmly said to her hey come here come
sit over here with me and she's like
what are you talkin here for a second
come sit over with me and she turned
around and saw it and it was like she
screamed and then the kids came running
down and it was like oh my god and I
realized at that moment I'm the guy who
has to deal with the spider
you know yeah I was turning around like
is there anyone else in the house like
there anyone here who's getting laid in
action my dad here yeah we're yeah and
I'm going and and how far away is Chris
Hemsworth right now
he'll probably you know wrestle the
thing yeah yeah but but no I had to do
it and so I you know and the spider
didn't care it wasn't going anywhere so
it kind of came and then it came on the
couch so it was on the arm of the couch
and his legs went over each side and I
had to get a bowl but not a normal bowl
like a like a cooking bowl like one of
those silver cooking bowls and then I'm
thinking right I can trap it but then
could it get out on ones that may wait I
got to get it on a flat surface and then
I got to get something like a book or
like a manila folder or something that
can cuz this thing's got weight I think
meant that it can read while it's in the
ball about giving it some reading
material as I took it outside that would
have been a good idea I wasn't thinking
straight clearly but no I couldn't put
you know how normally when you catch
something you a little spider you can
put a piece of paper
yeah and and this you needed to put like
a chunky book like and here's step over
that big guy and do it and then I
carried this giant thing out now as I
get the door please thank you and and
carried it out around and put it in
front of Chris's house where they don't
care at all no people in Australia I
mean I'm sure the Hemsworth still like
they're like yeah good eye Huntsman
No